- Alright I'm gonna close this hour out
with a holiday story that's
sure to make you smile.
This is What I'm Liking.
(energetic music)
- [Kelly] Earlier this year,
Schleich Toys posted
an unusual job opening,
Chief Storytelling Officer.
They wanted a kid who could make their
animals and place that's come to life.
So kids everywhere lined up for the role,
including eight year old Marcello,
who was first in line at the auditions
at FAO Schwarz in the Big Apple.
He must've set the bar high
for the other boys and girls
because he landed the
gig, along with $10,000.
We have, what?
We have the CSO on the line,
along with his proud mama, Tiffany.
So Marcello. Congratulations.
(crowd cheering)
Hello. Well, congratulations.
So how did you get the job?
What story did you tell?
- [Marcello] I actually told two stories.
My first one was about a
dinosaur birthday party.
So all these animals went back in time.
So for all the dinosaur birthday party,
so they got him a cake and
they asked what'd you wish for.
And he said, my wish already came true,
for having wonderful friends like you.
(crowd awws)
- [Kelly] Oh my Gosh.
You are so cute. Oh my Gosh.
How proud are you mama?
- [Tiffany] I am so proud. Honestly,
it's been such an incredible
journey for Marcello.
I mean, he has the biggest,
most wildest imagination.
So this is the perfect gig for him.
And the judges didn't know it,
last year that he was so sick.
He had strep infection,
it went to his brain.
He had rocky mountain spotted fever
and he had COVID all at once.
So it was like the craziest time for us.
We didn't know if we'd ever get him back.
Our talkative little boy,
he has come full circle.
We are so proud of him.
And now he's helping like,
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] Wow
- Do all these amazing things.
So we're so proud of him.
- [Kelly] I mean, what a,
what a warrior.
My sister literally is the only
person on the planet that I,
that I know that has had
rocky mountain spotted fever.
I'd never even heard about it before that.
And it's horrible. So God,
all those things at once man,
way to go survive. And that
you're a little warrior.
Way to go.
Well, thank you so much,
Marcello and Tiffany, congrats.
And I'm liking your post right now, right?
(crowd cheering)
And that's not how our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen at
the Kelly Clarkson Show
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly
and telling great stories.
Just like you Marcello.
So they're giving you a $1000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my Gosh, look at you.
- [Kelly] Alright thank you
all so much. Merry Christmas.